I'm shooting in the morning and then
prepping in the afternoon so um yeah
it's crazy
Troian Bellisario is showing off her
pretty little directing skills the PLL
star has stepped behind the camera this
week to direct episode 15 of the hit
dramas seventh season and only Ichi has
the scoop on how Troy was preparing for
her new role on set
I've just been rewatching pillow
episodes like like sucked at the screen
just being like what shots did they use
um but it's been wonderful I was just in
my lanes office yesterday and she was so
incredibly encouraging and said she said
to me what I would really maybe the most
calm which was that you know you have
the most loving crew and cast and all
they want is for you to have fun and
succeed and do a great job co-star Lucy
Hale has been especially supportive of
Trion's directorial debut the star
shared on Instagram that she was quote
honored to be in transfer scene and she
even gave her this succulent surprise
there is no other way Emily it was a
well thought-out plan when it ends up
like this it's called first-degree
murder I'm just curious as to know like
how are you gonna direct that girl who
plays Spencer because I've heard she's
has a serious attitude problem and she
doesn't take direction well so she and I
are gonna just we're gonna go to the
corner we're gonna work some stuff out
and hopefully Shay or Ashley will catch
it on snapchat for his enjoyment Disney
quietly crying in a corner like Oh God